reciprocals are be different to just
adding and subtraction because
reciprocals are at division okay
but nonetheless the whole point of this
kind of approach to things
is that we can do things by calculus we
are gonna do this by calculus by the way
we say we do you think my calculus would
you do things with all the old methods
but if you can think about something
visually you'd understand it in a much
deeper more functional way so before you
crack me on this right you can see this
is the actual function of interest it is
so but it has a component I've graphed
the denominator I'm gonna use that as my
own visual argument before we get into
that let's just think about what happens
if you know something about a number you
actually know a lot about its reciprocal
for example if you have function right
and at some point that function is equal
to zero what's the reciprocal of zero
infinity well I'm fine it's undefined
right it's undefined now that means that
on this graph
I don't exists which means in visual
terms undefined means you get a vertical
asymptote okay so anywhere that our
actual function is zero the reciprocal
of that function will have a vertical
asymptote because it can't exist there
right that's what vertical asymptotes
are in the same way I just think about
if the function is huge like some
astronomically large number right then
when you take the reciprocal of oh
really astronomically large above the
reciprocal should be really small right
it'll be small but it will still be
positive right if you think about a
really really negative know long like a
negative a million like that when you
take the reciprocal it's to be small but
the sign it comes for the ride
yeah like 100 negative a million is a
negative small number right does that
make sense now this is what you need
which is all you need and we can get a
really really good picture of this okay
so have a look y equals x cubed by this
what is my degree graph right you can
see it has an intercept
think about it what's the intercept is
zero it's going to be x equals one and y
equals zero okay so here I've got x
equals zero for the wine for the wine
sector to think why cuz I've just been
moved down
and this guy's would root across okay so
x equals negative 1 the function is 0 so
it's reciprocal we'll have a very classy
choice I get your roll around okay
now let's think about what's happening
on the right hand side of this graph
right X cubed minus 1 it's just
skyrocketing okay it's just growing and
there's no limit on how much it's gonna
go it's gonna grow faster and faster
faster faster in other words it's gonna
do this right it's become gonna become a
huge positive number so therefore it's
reciprocal would become a really little
positive number okay so this is climb
over to infinity so its reciprocal is
going to climb well it's going to hug
the excess of 2000 the x-axis that's
going to become asymptotic to y equals 0
okay so I'm gonna draw a riff here this
is what's happening over here on the
right okay this function is growing the
reciprocal is going to shrink real fast
thank you second row space over here the
left I can make a similar argument right
when you look at the extremities you
often get the same kind of behavior or
the same kind of behavior but opposite
right so this is a huge negative number
yes
so it's reciprocal will be a small
negative number right
no but reciprocal so again that's a
really bad doesn't it doesn't matter
principal anyway again I got this y
equals zero happening but I'm going to
be approaching from beneath right it's
going to come under here because it
needs to be maybe they're still okay all
right so far so good I've got a couple
of asymptotes yeah now what's the rest
of it doing okay
well let's think about again just like
we do with addition and subtraction
ordinates think about easy points are
there any easy points that we can do x
equals y or are you sick of x equals
here
okay I'm not because it's helpful right
this point here this intercept is what
equals negative one right what's the
reciprocal of negative one also negative
one it's it's a reciprocal yes so I know
that right now I already know I'm going
to be climbing towards this asymptote
right so I'm expecting like that kind of
behavior yes I'm coming close right over
here I'm expecting the same kind of
thing but from the top okay now let's
have a look closer into this vertical
asymptote what's going on right X cube
minus one we knew was getting big this
way what's it doing going the other
direction school it's getting smaller
it's getting super smaller fact it's
gonna even get to zero right now if your
denominator is getting small right
what's the fraction gonna do really it's
gonna get huge that's what reciprocals
do like they reciprocate they're doing
the opposite thing okay so this guy is
going to skyrocket up like that okay I
could actually find out what that values
where they intersect but it's not that
important right now
it's skyrocketing up okay this guy is
doing exactly the same thing but
negative you see that right it's
approaching zero but it's approaching
from beneath so therefore I'm getting
this behavior it's dropping like a rock
the last piece is well what's happening
in between here how do I connect here to
here okay now wouldn't be that bad I
conclude you to draw to say I'm gonna go
across I'm just gonna come straight
through okay however I wish your turn
take notes on you think about this guy
for a second because this is no random
point right think back to this I think
back to your geometrical applications of
calculus right what kind of point is
that point it's special
it's it's a stationary point and it's a
point of inflection right which makes it
a horizontal query inflection okay so
right here if I were to draw a tangent
it would be horizontal are you okay with
that I just for a moment right I think
with me give you two examples I don't
need to draw us suppose I ask you to
graph just a very simple bear with me
human be ask you to graph winding other
axes here um y equals negative one y cos
theta 1 so there's y equals zero the
access if I ask you to do y equals
negative 1 it would look like this
now what if unless you did you the
reciprocal function of this guy of y
equals negative 1 cubed me what would it
be it would be the same thing I mean we
noticed that right for this one point
its reciprocal just like one is it's
very reciprocal so therefore the
reciprocal function when very boringly
looks like this ok and here's the thing
right on this scale that we've got here
the whole graph X cubed minus one looks
very very curvy doesn't it okay
but you guys told me this is a
horizontal point of inflection if I were
to zoom in it's like zooming really
really far okay I can tell you what this
graph is going to look like if i zoom in
far enough it's gonna look like this do
you see that if I go in far enough right
there it's just gonna look horizontal
that's the whole point of a horizontal
point of inflection okay if i zoom in
really really far it's just gonna look
horizontal so therefore if the graph is
horizontal and that makes its reciprocal
horizontal then in here if the
denominator has a horizontal point
infection then its reciprocal will also
have a horizontal point of inflection
okay that's the last piece right
I know appreciating asymptotes okay and
I've got to get to this stationary
points this horizontal reflection so I'm
gonna do something like that okay
like how else can it get there it can't
climb down kind of like this because you
wouldn't get a horizontal point
does that make sense so that's why I've
got a level out like so okay so that's
why it changes concavity but then over
here I've got to get to this asymptote
right so now it bends the curves
downward like so that's a bit weird but
in fact now we're just going to confirm
this right because we did this all
visually in fact that should have been
exactly what we expected right because
watch this here's the graph right again
I'm gonna make this easy for us by
putting in index for putting the index
or makes it trivial to find out what the
derivative is right come on this is just
chain rule right help me out what I can
do do the outside first so the power
comes down at the front what happens to
power decreases by one and then it's
chain rule so I need to do the inside as
well right so put 3x squiddy happy with
that that's a bit gross let's tidy that
out I'll put the denominator where it
belongs down here okay now look don't do
any computation just look at that bit
right thanks
have a look at it don't do any
computation tell me what you know about
this graph just by looking at that
derivative it's got you stationary
points at x equals zero right there okay
but of course it's decreasing all this
way it's never going to come back up you
can do the second derivative if you
really want to test that out okay but
you don't even need to again look at it
don't do any computation right tell me
the denominator right what on the side
of the donor maybe for all X the side
must be poison it's a square right so
therefore the derivative the holder is
going to be negative right do you see
that because it's a million-five a
positive so it's decreasing all this way
and decreasing all this way right except
for this point here it's monotonically
decreasing okay so far it's going to be
dropping like a rock but you already
told me there's a point of inflection
there so if it's always decreasing it
can't possibly be a turning point it's
got to be a horrible to put in too much
but you can see I didn't need calculus
to argue any of that right I just looked
at this guy right and you thought I was
just doing a straight line how was it I
was doing that guy just zoomed in really
far okay